[Música]
quiero contarles una historia una
historia que trasciende los resultados
de una investigación pero para comenzar
me voy a presentar y les voy a contar a
qué me dedico me defino naturalista con
una fuerte vocación por la investigación
y esto lógicamente me llevó a transitar
una carrera con orientación biológica a
lo largo de la cual tuve la suerte de
encontrarme con excelentes maestros que
me abrieron las puertas al maravilloso
mundo de las plantas de este mundo lo
que más me fascinaba y me sigue
fascinando al día de hoy es su
diversidad no sólo el número de especies
sino también en formas las plantas
pueden presentar innumerables formas
desde las más simples hasta las más
complejas y en este universo de
diversidad existe un grupo de especies
cuyas formas a mí me intrigan por sobre
todas las otras me refiero a la familia
de las gramíneas o los comúnmente
llamados pastos es una familia muy rica
en especies distribuidas por todo el
mundo no hay rincón del planeta donde no
existe
y cuando abundan forman pastizales
naturales que son el abrigo de una
nutrida biodiversidad que dependen de
este bioma pero seguramente ustedes
conocen a esta familia por su valor
económico entre los miembros más
destacados están los famosos cereales
maíz arroz trigo avena especies que se
cultivan para forraje o para la
producción de biocombustibles entre
otros múltiples usos entonces una
familia económica cultural y
ambientalmente tan importante pero a la
vez con formas tan exclusivas entonces
me preguntaba cuáles eran esos elementos
que están originando o estén haciendo
que las gramíneas luzcan tan distintas
al resto de las plantas
en palabras más técnicas y más generales
la pregunta sería cuáles son las bases
biológicas de la diversidad de plantas
estas preguntas orientaron mis
investigaciones desde el inicio
entonces para empezar a encontrar una
respuesta lo primero que tenía que hacer
era entender esas formas saber
describirlas de manera adecuada entender
lo que estaba observando a simple vista
pero me di cuenta que estas formas que
estaba describiendo en realidad se
trataban de formas adultas era el
resultado final eran el resultado final
de la combinación de al menos dos
procesos importantes uno largo en el
tiempo la evolución y uno más corto y
dinámico en el tiempo el desarrollo y
ambos procesos tienen la particularidad
de estar comandados o dictados por unas
moléculas a las que se las conoce con el
nombre de proteínas cuya información
para producirlas o sintetizar las está
guardada en la famosa molécula de adn es
así que no me quedó otra que entrar en
el mundo de la genética
una dimensión para mí desconocida hasta
ese momento entonces combinando estos
cuatro aspectos de la biología de las
plantas que a mí me interesaban
la morfología el desarrollo la evolución
y las moléculas fue como llegué a
identificar un grupo de proteínas que se
comportaba de manera muy extraña se
salía de la norma eran muy distintas al
comportamiento que tenían con respecto
si las comparaba con moléculas que
estaba investigando de manera similar y
paralelas esto inmediatamente captó mi
atención y decidir seguir profundizando
el estudio en estas moléculas después de
superar algunas complicaciones técnicas
logré aislar tener conmigo a estas
moléculas en el formato adecuado para
ensayar las en el laboratorio y
eventualmente observar o evaluar si
tenían algún efecto sobre la forma de
las plantas pero nada es tan sencillo
mi vida personal y profesional habían
cambiado habían pasado aproximadamente 8
años estaba en una etapa de la carrera
donde sentía la necesidad de encontrar
un lugar para erradicar me más o menos
permanente
y al mismo tiempo me pasó algo muy
personal empecé a sentirme pese a sentir
incómoda con la forma en la que venía
investigando y parte de esta incomodidad
posiblemente se debía a que mis
proyectos no estaban estructurados para
darme resultados que tengan un impacto
en la comunidad
entonces empecé a sentir esta necesidad
de readaptar repensar mis proyectos en
busca de estos resultados que puedan ser
útiles para todos
esto fue muy difícil me hizo entrar en
lo que yo defino la etapa de pausa yo me
sentía que no me movía pero el resto
seguía moviéndose a mi alrededor
créanme que fue una sensación muy rara
muy difícil marcada una etapa marcada
por muchísima reflexión en donde
ensayaba escribía borraba y volví a
ensayar en este panorama complejo
también intentaba formar un grupo de
trabajo y poner en funcionamiento un
pequeño laboratorio
cuando sorpresivamente
se nos presentaron unos resultados que
nos hicieron salir repentinamente de la
pausa unos resultados que nos daban esa
esperanza de cambio ese cambio que yo
estaba buscando me imagino que se
preguntarán qué es lo que descubrimos
finalmente después de tanto esperar
había llegado el momento de ensayar
estas moléculas y para hacer este primer
ensayo elegimos
ensayar la sobre una especie modelo que
nos pueda dar resultados más o menos a
corto plazo
no queríamos esperar más
y lo primero que vimos fue sorprendente
las plantas que tenían nuestras
moléculas favoritas habían cambiado de
forma completamente no se parecían en
nada a sus controles es más hasta me
animo a decir que se parecían a partos
genial
entonces descubrimos algunos elementos
en este caso proteínas que cuando están
por sí solas son capaces de cambiarle la
forma a las plantas
pero después nos detuvimos un poco y
empezamos a observar estas plantas en
más detalle y vimos que estas plantas
vivían más pero mucho más
a aquellos a los que les gustan los
números las plantas controles suelen
vivir 8 semanas
nuestras plantas vivieron un año un año
y medio
o más fue muy difícil determinar cuando
terminaba su ciclo de vida
la planta se había un vuelto inmortales
eternas
y no sólo eso también notamos que eran
más productivas
para medir producción en plantas uno
tiene un montón de indicadores nosotros
elegimos optar o está optamos por medir
lo que se llama biomasa aérea es decir
pesar con una balanza todo lo que crece
por arriba del suelo y comparar los
controles con el descubrimiento y estas
últimas eran capaces de acumular hasta
casi 50 veces más de biomasa aérea
y esta acumulación extra de biomasa se
daba siempre no importa qué parámetros
de tiempo usáramos y por debajo del
suelo también descubrimos maravillosos
atributos que volvían a estas plantas
más vigorosas y resilientes es decir
resistentes al estrés y lo bueno de este
método que aparentemente habíamos
descubierto de prolongar la vida de las
plantas de volverlas más productivas en
términos de biomasa al menos y
devolverlas más las siguientes era un
método que era fácilmente trasladable
por peces que se cultivan que tienen
valor económico entonces instalamos un
nuevo objetivo en nuestro laboratorio
trabajemos con estas moléculas con la
información que nos dan para lograr
innovar y generar cultivos que vivan más
y produzcan más
en el mismo lugar
pero quiero usar los últimos minutos que
me quedan para contarles en realidad
algo más divertido algo más valioso que
fue en realidad lo que pasó después de
este descubrimiento que hizo que me
enamorara de un proceso y no de un
resultado teníamos dos caminos a seguir
el camino de hacer público
inmediatamente nuestros resultados con
una publicación el camino de la
publicación es un camino que no
conocemos que es complicado pero estamos
acostumbrados a lidiar con sus problemas
y un camino que para nosotros era
completamente desconocido el camino de
la innovación de la vinculación
tecnológica y eventualmente una
transferencia
qué hacemos
para tomar esta decisión realmente
tuvimos que salir de nuestra zona de
confort y empezar a golpear puertas de
expertos una de las cosas que podríamos
nos podría ayudar a tomar la decisión
era conocer si este método este método
que habíamos descubierto era lo
suficientemente original para reclamar
la propiedad intelectual
propiedad intelectual un término que
desconocía que conocemos
superficialmente pero no en profundidad
y sus implicancias entonces nos vimos
muy motivados y sentimos la necesidad de
perfeccionarnos así que como grupo
tomamos la decisión de salir y
capacitarnos pues así que realizamos
capacitaciones en inteligencia
tecnológica comunicación de la ciencia y
la tecnología y hasta nos animamos a
hacer capacitaciones para entender lo
que son los modelos de negocio y cómo
diseñar un negocio de hecho se nos
ocurrió nuestro propio negocio
qué quiero decir con esto todo este
torbellino de nuevas ideas y nuevos
conceptos todo lo que nos estaba pasando
nos permitió pensar muchísimo más lejos
de lo que estamos acostumbrados
salir de lo técnico y pensar muchísimo
más allá e incluso situar nuestros
proyectos en otro contexto
y no solo este camino que tímidamente
empezamos a transitar nos potenció en
ideas sino también que nos dio la llave
de acceso para conocer e interactuar con
otros grupos de trabajo
un día me encuentro discutiendo ideas de
manera interdisciplinaria el trabajo
interdisciplinario es maravilloso es muy
rico era algo que quería lograr a lo
largo de mi carrera y finalmente lo
había logrado
encontramos socios socios que nos
valoran nos escuchan nos comprenden y
están dispuestos a darle el formato
adecuado a nuestras ideas para
concretarlos
imagínense que todo esto como grupo
laboratorio chico nos dio mucha
fortaleza nos fortaleció y nos permitió
muchísimo crecimiento profesional y
grupal todo este proceso está haciendo
maravilloso tan maravilloso es que los
resultados pasan a un segundo plano hoy
nos encontramos iniciando un nuevo
camino dimos el primer paso y un camino
que tiene connotaciones pesadas como
largo tedioso complicado riesgoso donde
el fantasma del fracaso aparece todos
los días pero hasta nosotros poco nos
importa porque tenemos puesto el valor
en otro aspecto en el aprendizaje en las
oportunidades que empiezan a aparecer y
en los aliados que se empiezan a sumar
en este camino
todo este proceso nos ha transformado
nos ha transformado la manera de pensar
la forma de trabajar y nuestra relación
con el trabajo
y esto es lo que lo que más valoro y lo
que trato de comunicarle a diario a mi
grupo
no importa hacia donde lleguemos no
sabemos a dónde vamos a llegar
pero disfrutemos del proceso
creo entonces que
para repensar nuestros proyectos lo que
sabemos hacer lo que amamos a hacer pero
en busca de esos resultados que pueden
ser útiles para la comunidad creo que es
un aspecto de la ciencia digno de
conocer
y la buena noticia
es que es un proceso un camino que está
disponible en forma gratuita para todo
aquel que lo quiera buscar
este fue nuestro mayor descubrimiento
gracias
[Aplausos]